circulent c'est sur la scène du pavillon
waldeck-rousseau à gryon cours en piste
quatre équipes pour cette épreuve face à
un jury d'experts du challenge du
partage et du plaisir c'était le but de
ces danse d'improvisation de hip hop yen
ce concept organisé pour la première
fois dans le cadre du festival
pulsations urbaine
à
- le hip hop d'une concept c'est un
trait d'union entre le battle et la
scène c'est tout ce qui se passe pour
fabriquer une création hip hop c'est à
dire danser avec des contraintes des
accessoires contre avec d'autres
personnes
voilà c'est tout ça qui fait qu' on est
dans un système de jeu
l'un après l'autre les danseurs se joue
de l'improvisation et démontrent leur
talent sur les bancs les autres
participants encourage à venir en
attendant leur tour
sur scène les danses s'enchaînent en
rite ou plus lente à l'honneur la
technique la théâtralité
on écoute ce jour là l'équipe gagnante
voyait son projet de création
accompagner les diffuser par les
partenaires du territoire